alors
ne m'oblige pas à me répéter et jerry g
losail gelé vraiment juste là à tout
moment donne moi de semaine de mars
combien du doigt un sacré paquet il sort
d'où ce type
on aurait dû se croiser plus tôt
tu es un bon ça se voit personne
n'arrive à la cheville
le secret pour gagner
700 foot de gagner quoi et on apprend
saut j'ai suivi un mauvais plan j'ai
plus le droit à l'erreur
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides ok je vais
t'apprendre
où est passé l'argent je peux me refaire
c'est bien compris à mon signal tu
parles
ce que tu veux thierry j'étais
complètement foutu mais d'un coup de
voilà
c'est super risqués comme co
on n'a pas le droit de se louper
serai jamais un auteur à trois on fait
tout péter
bon c'est ça que tu veux un
on ne gagne pas à tous les coups